MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to DataVis DevTalk.
I'm your host Minhaz
Kazi, developer advocate
for Data Studio.
In this video, we'll discuss
how you can share and publish
your connector.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's say you have just
developed your first community
connector.
You're conscious
about your health
and track your daily activities.
So you've created a Google Fit
connector to track your Google
Fit data in Data Studio.
You have tested
the functionality,
added helpful error messages,
and created separate testing
and production deployments.
So the connector is good
to go, but at this point,
the connector can be
used only on your account
since you have not
shared it with others.
When a user uses a community
connector under the hood,
Data Studio is
executing functions
from the connector's script
on the user's behalf.
Therefore, the
user's account must
have read access to the script.
Otherwise, Data Studio
cannot execute the script.
If you're working a team
to develop the connector
or want a few trusted users
to try out the connector,
you must provide read access
to your connector strip
to these users.
But what if you want to share
the connector with everyone?
You found your Google Fit
connector to be very helpful,
and you think others can
also benefit from it.
For that, the first step would
be to share your apps script
project by link.
Head over to that script
environment, open your project,
hit the Share button
on the top right,
and click on Get Sharable Link.
Make sure that the option
anyone with the link can view
is visible.
If you're in a G
Suite organization,
this option might
not be available
based on your
administrative settings.
In this specific case, you can
either talk to your G Suite
admin to enable this
option or copy your script
to a non-restricted account
like a Gmail account.
At this point, all users have
read access to your script.
Keep in mind that unless a user
has the exact link to your app
script project, they will not
be able to view the code in app
script environment.
Now to share the connector
with other users,
you will also need to get
the correct deployment link.
Open your connector in the
app script environment,
click on Publish from the
Menu, and select Deploy
from Manifest.
This will show you a list of all
deployments for your connector.
We will cover versioning
and deployments
in a separate video.
From this interface, copy the
appropriate deployment link
and share it with others.
You can share the link
through email, social media,
or your own blog.
Anyone who goes to
this deployment link
will be able to
use your connector,
configure it, connect to
their own Google Fit data,
and create their own
separate dashboards.
That's pretty neat.
You can get greater
visibility for your connector
by publishing it to the Data
Studio connector gallery.
If the connector gets
published, all Data Studio users
will be able to
view the connector
while exploring or searching
through the gallery.
You can publish your
connector in two ways,
either as a partner connector
or as an open source connector.
If you publish as a
partner connector,
you'll need to support, deploy,
and maintain the connector
yourself.
You can follow the partner
connector guidelines
and submit a review
request to get started.
If the connector
passes the review,
it'll be included in the
gallery as a partner connector.
Publishing in this way helps
you and your organization
to get more exposure,
add your own branding,
and also monetize
your connector.
On the other hand, you can
publish as an open source
connector.
In that case, the connector
is deployed by the Data Studio
DevRel team and supported
by the community.
You can start the process
by submitting a pull request
to a repository.
Link is in the description.
Once the pull
request is approved,
your connector will be
showcased in the gallery
as an open source connector.
This is a great way for
you to showcase your code.
Publishing your connector
helps to get better visibility,
reach a bigger audience,
and provide better value
to your existing users.
You also become eligible
to be considered
for promotional activities.
So we recommend that if
you build a connector,
you should publish it.
However, keep in
mind that you don't
have to publish to share
your connector with others.
You can share by link
even without publishing
and then just give the
deployment to your LT users.
Hopefully you find this
sharing and publishing
overview for community
connectors useful.
You can always go to
our developer site
at
developers.google.com/DataStudio
for more information.
If you like this video, stay
tuned on the GCP channel
for more Data Studio content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]